今天要分享的是歌词创作中的三要素
一人称代词的使用
二韵脚文字的掌握
三情感的最大公约数
哪三要素呢
再重复一遍
人称代词的使用韵脚
文字的掌握情感的最大公约数以及画面态度
情感情绪
故事线
所谓的三要素
五结构
首先我们先进入今天的主题
人称代词的使用
所有的人称代词是什么
简单来讲就是你我他我大家都知道
就是第一人称
所以讲话的那个人有时候你看他小说的语法
有些小说会用我
我发现了他们其实很神秘
我看到了他们偷偷的跑出教堂外
用我当第一人称的视野
有些小说是用全知观点
所有的全职观点他就没有很明显的
我
因为呢全职观点是
好像大家都在一个范围内发生一些故事
所以他用全知观点去形塑小说的整体的氛围
只要故事的主角出现的时候
他不是用我
我看到他们离开教堂
而是用DAVID离开教堂哦
这是全职观点
他没有用第一人称的视角去讲故事
所以你看看小说语法也这么多
这么丰富
第一人称也有全知观点
因此我们歌词也是有的
所谓的人称代词
第一人称就是我讲话的那个人
第二人称是你
你是指一般人或者是听话的那个人
第三人称是其他方
第三方就是他还有一种是负数
比如说我们你们他们就是负数
就是两个人以上
我们都知道他们从教堂离开哦
那个就不是只有你而已
这个就负数了
所以很容易去判断人称代词
那人称代词在歌词里面有什么样的重要性呢
基本上这个就是歌词跟诗最大的区隔
歌词很多都是拟人化的
甚至通篇他都没有出现过
他在讲个现象
讲个情绪
他讲乡愁讲了老半天
他用落叶去形容孤独
他可能用风语去形容心情
很多的隐喻
很多间接的词汇
它就是不用我去讲故事
这是诗的语法很常见
而且诗本来就应该这么做
诗的想象空间一般而言都是比歌词来的深跟广
所以它很多元
诗的题材很多元
但歌词大多数会局限在情感
或者说他本来就应该这么做
因为歌词服务的对象是听歌跟唱歌的人
所以歌词不外乎讲三个感情
爱情
亲情友情
绝大多数都是在这个范围内
所以呢人称代词在歌词的关键位置
非常非常的重要
我举一个范例
就是爱在西元前
像爱在西元前的副歌的第一行就有人称代词
我给你的爱写在西元前
深埋在美索不达米亚平原
几十个世纪后出土
发现泥板上的字迹依然清晰可见
请注意哦
如果这个副歌的第一行没有你跟我呢
基本上你感情没办法进入哦
这是很重要的一个区隔
那我在唱我的故事吗
还是在唱我们的故事
听歌跟唱歌的人的情感不容易进去
不容易感同身受
不容易设身处地
有一个想象的画面
因为你少了你我他
我再举另外一段歌词给大家听
古巴比伦王颁布了汉谟拉比法典
刻在黑色的玄武岩
距今已3700多年
完全没有你我他就是觉得很酷啊
然后呢你的情感进不去哦
因为没有人称代词好
第二行
你在橱窗前凝视碑文的字眼
我却在旁静静欣赏你那张我深爱的人
因为他喜欢的这个女生在看他喜欢的谷物
而我在看它里面有你跟我很重要很重要
歌词的词汇一定要人称代词
听歌跟唱歌的人才知道角色扮演
所以有时候很多催泪的情歌一听很感动
特别是你失恋的时候
或者有相同遭遇的时候
因为呢他有最直截了当的人称代词
我或者是你或者是我
我们我再举一首歌的例子给大家看
这首歌是之前课堂上也有分享过的
叫威廉古堡
藤蔓植物爬满了伯爵的坟墓
古堡里一片荒芜
长满了杂草的泥土一样
听起来很酷
但是呢就是空间感而已
有什么情绪勾引我了没有
并没有好
第二行
不会骑扫把的胖女巫
用拉丁文念咒语
啦啦啦呜
她养的黑猫笑起来像哭子
这里面就有他了
人称代词很重要哦
你情感进去哦
有故事画面了
因为有人在了
有人的存在了
所以人称代词在歌词的范畴里是至关重要的
也要注意一些状况
譬如说等很多友情的歌
基本上你会用我或我们这是没有问题的
因为我们是负数嘛
然后有些友情的歌或讲乡愁的歌
不见得会出现你
但只要是情歌的范畴
基本上一定有我跟你不见得有他
那如果更丰富的话
基本上你我他都会出现有种状况
基本上不会出现
就是整个人称代词里面只有我跟他没有你
你是听话的那个人
是讲话的对象
因为他是第三人
你他不见得知道你在想他
或者是你在说他
所以比较合理的歌词结构应该是你我他都有
或者是只有我跟你也可以
只要是情歌的创作格局很少出现
只有我而已
除非这个歌是讲那种很特殊的状况
就非情歌的路线
可能讲那种孤独感呐或乡愁啊
那可能会有油脂油脂
基本上算是一种人称代名词或是谁
谁是疑问的代词
谁也是人嘛
可能谁啊游子啊
然后我啊那可能不会出现
你因为他不是情歌的范畴
所以这个时候没有出现
你跟他就是合理的
所以切记人生代词虽然很重要
很好用
但是不能误用
不能错用
否则整首歌词的故事结构性就变得支离破碎
甚至很突兀
第二个是韵脚文字的使用
因为歌词文字是依附着音乐而有了完整的生命
而它完整生命的前提是建立在船上
那如果你有韵脚
会让唱歌跟听歌的人有个听觉的记忆
情感会更容易进入
而且听起来他的音乐的节奏是有画面感
跟丝不一样
我一再的强调
整首新的诗歌
你很难一字不漏的背诵
但歌词可以
歌词因为有韵脚的辅助
至于怎么押韵脚
之前的课堂有分享过了
就是歌词的段落
假设八小节有四行
怎么压怎么压
记得哦
有看的人就知道了
韵脚这项创作上所必备的一个要素
不是那么的神秘或是那么的难懂
基本上会写歌词
或对歌词有兴趣或喜欢唱歌的人都知道
绝大多数的流行歌词都有韵脚作为一种辅助
所以呢在此我是大概的分享一下
因为手头上刚好有一个爱在线前
像这个也是一运到底的歌词
祭司神殿征战弓箭是谁的
从前弓箭跟从前
你们有没有注意到一个小细节
就是我双数压技师
你有鸭神殿
有鸭征战
没有压弓箭
有押
就是说神殿弓箭谁的
从前这三个字是有押韵的哦
这是我的一个小巧思
就是纵使它只是单字
但是它是四个独立的片语
所以我就压他的二跟四就是神殿跟弓箭好
下面是喜欢在人潮中
你只属于我的那画面面也有押韵
所以这整首歌是押同一个韵脚
这是很好判读的
韵脚
我倒是认为不太需要去强调
因为所有的歌词
90%以上都是有韵脚的辅助
然后再跟音乐配合
再来我们介绍情感的最大公约数
公约数这个词汇是数学的
数学里面的好
我们把它借来使用
就是越多数人会遇到的情感状态
越适合写成流行歌词
很好理解吧
就是说有时候你听情歌的时候
你会发现说这个歌怎么那么悲伤
好像我现在的心情或者这个歌的那种愁绪
或者这个歌的那种小暧昧
怎么跟我的环境很相近
是因为我们填词者是用客观的角度去说故事
所以我们会把最多数人会遇到的情感状态
写成流行歌词
你的故事
他的遭遇被我们听进来之后
我们就用歌词文字去还原我们听到的情感状态
而这听来的情感状态是最客观的
所以歌词的共鸣性比斯来的高很多
因为我们不为自己的情感服务
我们创作的歌只是为歌手
专辑专案或是听歌的人服务
这样子有个好处
就是我们去经营文字的结构跟故事的时候
不太容易有主观的意识
而且呢我们的失恋是大家的共同经验值
我们的暗恋
我们的背叛
我们的第三者
我们的劈腿
我们的始终如一
就是大家生活的经验值
所以呢你可以在流行音乐里面
找到你的喜怒哀乐
找到你的困境
找到你的悲伤
找到你的开心
找到你的小甜蜜
就像之前写告白气球一样
这种带点甜味的情歌就是多数人会感同身受
英文所描述的语境跟画面感跟用语
是多数人的生活经验值里面会遇到的
会遇到的
所以记得写歌词的时候
一定要用客观的角度去找情感的最大公因数
而不要去写那种很罕见的遭遇
或是很奇怪
个人的孤独
除非你今天是创作型歌手
你走的是所谓非主流的路线
那你的专辑其实就会很多元
你可以讲困顿
讲寂寞
讲愤世技术
讲批判
都可以关心环保
各种议题你都可以写
因为你是词曲一起创作
而且你的主轴就在于说出自己的观点
这个时候你可能就跟大多数的流行歌词
可以做切割
这是没有问题的
因为歌词的创作本来就很多元
很多的类别可以选择
只是这不是主流的写法
真正主流的情歌要获得共鸣的
一定是大家的生活
情感上会感受到大家的情感认同上会有归属感
甚至最后形成一个共同记忆
之前在课堂上有分享过流行歌词
是社会的共同记忆
这所有的共同记忆就包含着你的成长
你的青春
因为你想想看
在某个时空背景
十七八岁的时候
跟一群朋友追逐一个歌手或者乐团
不管他的演唱会还是他的专辑
讨论彼此分享
分享的这种记忆区块会停留在你脑海里面
日后大家聊的都是某一场演唱会
某一个专辑
而不是聊哪一次的考试
谁考不好
谁考了几分
人的大脑很特别
他会把所有不同的顺序跟记忆分开处理
学习的记忆
它储存在一个领域
跟朋友互动的区域
但是真正跟朋友可以交流的
通常都是相处的记忆
像这次的歌词创作班
基本上你们有一个群体
有个班级
那你就可以有共同记忆了
因为你可以跟朋友分享学习的心得
而且我们会有作业
作业的时候你就可以交流
所以呢参与这个歌词创作班
除了凝聚共同的记忆之外
你还可以找到志同道合的朋友
而这志同道合的朋友
你们会相互的激励
相互的砥砺
甚至可能3年后
5年后只有两个人在这个圈子流行音乐圈
那也无妨
其他人也留下了他青春时期的一个学习的记忆
共同记忆就是这样行硕来的
你传唱的歌居然打中我的心
为什么打中我的心
因为你叙事的角度跟故事的结构跟内容跟遭遇
基本上一般人都遇得到
所以这样子的歌最适合写成流行音乐
记得对于作词者而言
我们的歌词文字是为了别人的情感服务
不是为我们自己服务
因为作词是一项工作
是一项职业
你拿出来的作品必须符合人家的期待
它是工业链的一环
所以我一开始才会说
绝大多数的歌词
绝大多数的状况下都不能归类为文学作品
因为我们有点像工业产业链
你知道吗
我们是其中的一环
我们不能膨胀自己
把自己的需求
主观意识无限的放大是不对的
想想看哦
唱片工业链里面词曲编曲制作
配唱歌手vocal mv
甚至最后还有行销跟专案的合作结合
这种种的环节里面
我们歌词作词者的身份就是其中一环
我们这一款怎么可以忽略掉别人的需求呢
这是不对的
所以切记创作歌词是为了别人的情感服务
不是我们自己
当然啦
如果你遭遇到的情感状态
是多数人都会遇到的状况
以你的情感为主轴去写的歌也会感动人
所以你的体验你的挫折
如果是一般人也会遇到的
那你把你的故事写成歌词
那也是合理的
因为你不是写个很冷门的
很孤独的在偏乡啊
然后什么遗世独立呀
然后一个人困顿
然后觉得孤独
宇宙跟你为敌
那个就不对了
记得歌词的生命在传唱
那传唱的先决条件
你必须有别人的情感共鸣
别人的情感共鸣
你创作必须客观
必须为别人的情感而服务
这是歌词创作者自己要体现出的一个核心
就是我们创作的价值来自于哪里哦
为了别人的情感服务
那其实这个当下也浮到自己的情感了
因为我描述的状况是大多数人遇到的遭遇
所以呢朝这个方向去发展
歌词就不会离题太远
记得歌词创作是一门很特别的一个职业类别
那在这个职业类别里面
你要形塑自己的主观
但是写出来却要客观
这个一点都不矛盾哦
就像我我对于很多事情都有自己主观的判断
举例来讲
像星座
很多年轻朋友都很关心或者是会聊星座的话题
其实我跟你说
我一点都不相信星座
因为星座我研究过
我当初加入唱片公司的时候
我们周同学的歌名不是很踊跃吗
那个年代歌迷回航卡还没有新作这一栏
但是有生日
我不想哪里来的时间
我就把几千份的歌迷回行卡的生日换算成星座
我要验证我的论述嘛
哇几千份诶
我统计了几个礼拜
你知道吗
诶我发现那个曲线表他不是有意义的
所以有意义是突然某一个星座高出其他星座
可能20%或30
但是我印象中那个曲线是这样子
这样子没有特别的鲜明
而且星座调查一定要有一个数据
12个星座你不能只调查120个人
抽样太少不客观
但是星座是人际关系的话题
星座是人际关系的润滑剂
所以也没那么严肃
一听到跟你相同星座啊
你是什么星座就很开心了
没有星座这样子的论述
就是代表说你看问题的角度在哪里
流行音乐的创作跟任何艺术领域的创作都一样
你要看的够宽够远
你就会看到别人看不到的区块
歌词绝对是这样子
像我当初为什么会创造中国风的歌词
你要具备不可被取代性
在这个行业里面
所以那时候我就开始研究所谓的国风
歌曲怎么写
从一开始的娘子东风破发如雪
烟花易冷
菊花台一系列的写上来
然后慢慢我才发现说哦
这样子的语法结构可以让文字很美
为什么
因为古风歌词的文字的韵味适合经营它的美感
一般的都会感的通俗流行歌词比较不好经营
因为他有修辞学
修辞学会让你文字有跳跃感
有画面感
有空间感
很多种技巧
很多种实验的形式都在这堂课里面
你可以学得到
而且甚至学到跟歌词以外的领域
但是都是在训练你了
训练你的独立判断的能力
然后再形说出自己的创作风格来
所以同学们记得哦
每一堂课的每一个论述跟观点都要好好的学习
纵使没有直接跟歌词创作有关
但是你相信我日后会发酵的
我教你的态度跟观点
看事物的角度
日后会在你心中种下一颗种子
慢慢它会发芽的
这堂课
你学到了两个歌词的技术跟看事物的角度
希望这两样会让你受用无穷